alors c'est ici qu'on a démarré en 2005
on cherchait une une boulangerie une
boulangerie pâtisserie avec mon épouse
et on a été charmé par le côté vieille
rue côté historique avec la vue sur le
château de blois
très vite le succès là vous dire que
jean françois l or savent de quoi ils
parlent
lui est maître pâtissier elle a un cap
et de pâtisseries et connaît la vente
quatre ans plus tard il voit plus grand
l'aventurier 2 démarre avec un concept
bien particulier et une ambiance très
maîtrisée chaque détail compte
c'est vrai mes photos de famille de mon
mari jean françois et du coup on voit
même un air de famille avec des mots et
du coup ça fait pas concept aseptisé
comme on voit beaucoup dans les zones
industrielles
voilà c'est vraiment c'est au ranch et
feuilletons de chez nous parallèlement
il crie ce laboratoire
ici on élabore et puis 30 personnes y
confectionne les gâteaux le macaron
c'est vraiment très technique et pour
vraiment maîtriser le produit font faire
tous les jours sur la même personne qui
réalise la recette de la pâte à macao
ce jour-là 6000 macarons caramel au
beurre salé sortiront de l'atelier ils
seront vendus dans les neuf boutiques de
la région et les cinq franchises soit
une véritable chaîne créée en seulement
huit ans une force qui permet à
l'entreprise d'investir dans le matériel
produire en grande quantité et réduire
ainsi les coûts de production exemple
avec le praliné
on achète noisette on sélectionne aux
amandes et on fait ça avec voyons gratte
les vanille en gousse pour avoir
vraiment un goût du praliné qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient vraiment au top car
le credo de notre pâtissier c'est la
qualité
pour cela il s'est entouré des meilleurs
le plus important aujourd'hui ça va être
le goût et
le calibrage de toul et parfois qu'on
aura mis dedans si on est bien si ça te
convient cette plaie ça c'est très
important
dernière mise au point du futur bûche de
noël au conseil angelo musa meilleur
ouvrier de france ces chefs pâtissiers
d'un palace parisien très réputé rien de
moins et nous apporte surtout le goût
parce que à un moment donné ont goûté on
a l'habitude d'avoir nos produits de
beauté nos produits on se rend plus
compte il est là un petit peu pour nous
ouvrir les yeux et nous faire comprendre
bah là où c'est bien et là où c'est
moins bien
[Musique]
talleu
le moelleux avec une vie suivant les
textures et hop le petit croustillant et
crémeux
crème vanille
comme ça on est gay c'est vrai
du beau du bon des parkings pour les
clients et une ouverture 7 jours sur 7
les feuilletons tout compris au commerce
moi je n'ai pas à rougir de ce
développement parce que on a on n'a pas
perdu notre âme dans le développement
moi j'ai la même façon de travailler que
dans la rue des trois marchands à blois
je n'ai pas changé de méthode de travail
une réussite qui va se poursuivre d'ici
la fin de l'année l'enseigné comptera
trois nouvelles franchises beauvais
limoges et lorient
[Musique]